Elements exist in three different phases:
solid, liquid, and gas.
The boundaries of these phases are best illustrated
using phase diagrams.
Phase diagrams allow us to predict the element’s
phase based on the temperature and pressure
of its environment.
The dividing lines are indicative of physical
processes such as melting and boiling.
At the boundary the element experiences a
fusion of the phases (Imagine an ice cube
melting or water boiling).
On the phase diagram, there exist two interesting
points: the triple point and the critical
point.
The triple point, the intersection of all
three phases, is the temperature and pressure
at which the solid, liquid and gaseous forms
of a pure substance coexist in equilibrium.
The particles of the substance are loosely
arranged between the rigidity of a solid and
the free movement of a gas.
The critical point is the end point of phase
equilibrium curve between liquid and gas.
Beyond this point, they’re indistinguishable
and form a supercritical fluid, which is a
substance that behaves like a gas but still
dissolves substances like liquids can.
Supercritical fluids are useful because they
allow us to extract one substance from another.
In many ways, a supercritical fluid’s function
can be similar to that of water, a liquid
solvent.
For example, to extract an object’s salt
coating, we can soak the object in water to
dissolve the salt, then boil the water to
leave the salt behind.
This works because salt and water evaporate
at different temperatures and pressures.
In the case of supercritical fluids, we can
dissolve a substance, then lower the pressure
to turn supercritical fluids into gas.
This causes previously dissolved particles
of the substance to fall down for easy collection.
Compared to regular liquids, supercritical
fluids have the advantage of flowing more
easily.
This lets them quickly spread dissolved substances
to make space for more, meaning they dissolve
things faster.
Because gas-like supercritical fluids are
unaffected by surface tension, they can also
get to spots that regular fluids can’t get
to.
One application of supercritical fluids is
the decaffeination of coffee.
Previous decaffeination processes used dichloromethane,
a chemical known to cause cancer, so coffee
beans required treatment after decaffeination
to ensure their safety.
These processes also removed oils from the
beans, ruining their taste and texture.
Nowadays, we use supercritical CO2 instead.
The CO2 passes over coffee beans, dissolves
their caffeine, then releases the caffeine
once the pressure drops and the CO2 becomes
a gas.
The beans’ oil is left unchanged and up
to 95% of the caffeine is reclaimed for use
in other products, like energy drinks or caffeine
pills.
Among other uses, supercritical fluids can
extract proteins like diterpenes (antioxidants)
and tetraterpenes (carotenes).
Supercritical CO2 can also be used to extract
vitamin E from fruits and vegetables, or even
to isolate floral fragrance from flowers.
Near the critical point, substances rapidly
fluctuate between liquid-like and vapor-like
volumes, resulting in a cloudy appearance.
This phenomenon, called critical opalescence,
has fascinated scientists for centuries and
been observed in a series of substances, most
popularly CO2.
Scientists at Brown University recently observed
the critical opalescence in liquid helium
for the first time, suggesting that this phenomenon
is universal.
Here’s a video of their experiment.
We heat the liquid helium at about 4.2 K,
and we can see the liquid start boiling.
After about 5 minutes, the liquid level gradually
disappears and the substance enters its supercritical
phase.
Then we stop heating the liquid when the temperature
reaches 5.4 K.
The liquid temperature lowers and as it approaches
the critical point, critical opalescence occurs
at about 5.23 K.
The fluid becomes cloudy because of the density
fluctuation.
As the temperature drops further, the liquid
level re-appears indicating the phase separation
between liquid and vapor.
This video would make Albert Einstein very
happy, since it helps prove the theory he
proposed in his paper on the theory of opalescence.